it's up its down its up and now it is
back down again precipitously and
sharply and while you can thank the most
current rise to demand from China the
drop now comes as china central bank
denied bitcoins equal legal status with
real currencies last week as it reminded
the public of financial risks just a
half hour after the statement from
people's bank of china the bitcoin price
dropped almost twenty percent ok come to
go do often so andrew Berry without you
can see the red line here it represents
the downtrend very short period so then
tells a lot of risks so what is a
Bitcoin well it's a currency baby really
born in November 2008 bitcoins are sixty
four digit numbers stored in digital
accounts traded on professional online
platforms and can be converted into real
money the most recent rise hunger for
bitcoins came from China in early April
when bitcoins exchange rate against the
US dollar topped 12 266 yes haha was
about 120 US dollars on October 10th but
has risen to 1200 US dollars that is 10
times it looks even more armies was
shorten the period the price rose from
30 US dollars to 1200 yourselves within
30 days that was only in 30 days but
with popularity comes risk constant
dramatic fluctuations right now China
ranks first in terms of Bitcoin trade
value about sixty percent of the world's
total more than thirty trading platforms
have been established in China where an
average 100,000 bitcoins are traded
daily oh wow eight of them at the price
of 550 you on each and then I sold some
each time I'd appreciate to a certain
level now I still own two of them each
more than 7,000 you are that has come
down quite a bit still appetite is
growing despite the uncertainty as to
the legitimacy and credibility of the
Bitcoin but as they say no risk no
reward Angelo Bloomberg